[Music]
[Applause]
me and Tommy are going alligator hunting
you excited Tom I'm buddy starting at
this fence right here we got 16,000
acres that's 52 miles down to this Jesus
yeah through the cypress swamps view for
country mostly deer turkey bunch
alligators need that Sun to come out
it's a 44 caliber bang stick that's
inherently yeah you'll get this pull
away from it and go like that okay
that's it but is they put a bullet in
there and then used to be hit it it
fires the bullet into his head yeah
that's what kills them for you know
that's brass so this is the fishable
ugly stick a tiger rod big ol LED on
there nice we're not gonna have a whole
lot of opportunities with this ring
that's pretty rough kind of hard they're
not gonna sit there what I'm gonna say
anything Tommy's just cool right here
you like driving in the back of a pickup
like this we should always drive like
this right now the rain makes it tricky
to hunt the alligators because you know
the alligators don't want to Sun
themselves when it's all crated like
that plus it ripples the water makes it
harder to see them when they stick their
heads out oh man this is gorgeous look
at this country there's beer right there
there's a little little Gator down there
that hole well guys we got big plans for
these Gators here I've got a boot maker
in El Paso who's gonna let us do some
filming and show us how to make
alligator skin cowboy boots I am more
than a little excited about that that'll
take about a year though between the
tanning and making everything in the
short term we get to have ourselves some
alligator steaks and alligator nuggets
and I know this boy's been talking about
that for a long time
alligators good Gator down there here
how do we tell
[Music]
all right ami forgot point the camera
seat okay no no he's just keeping him
from biting him pin him up here but
let's just listen to what they're saying
okay so he got up his back right here
see longest clicking foot on his back
you can knee down yeah straddling yeah
you know top living right here traveling
yeah you need you don't need any help
right here you wait on me get both hands
out here on his neck you can't get you
as long as you don't like oh you got him
all right
you gotta go tell me how you like it oh
my God look at me Tommy let go here we
go yeah don't let go he's gonna he's
gonna get his a there you go now back
straight up yeah he's going backwards
there you go over by the truck
rao's Tommy all right Tommy you want you
want to see mama freak out we're gonna
send her a text picture of that I feels
like that's just brush I think I follow
them popping it well there you go I
buggered that one up I just did exactly
what he told me not to do just gave it
the tiniest bit of slack if that was a
fish wouldn't have been a big deal but
these alligators are so armored getting
the barb in of his heart what mom mom
would just put takes it back oh my with
some exclamation points
something about be safe we're being very
safe baby don't worry a lot of hunts you
just can't take kids on this this is
definitely a more family-friendly hunt
man I wish I'd taken Nathan along with
me he'd love just ride along
[Music]
there's a spot here where an 18-wheeler
full of green beans spilled alone we're
gonna get ourselves some free green
beans bass not why not man hell that
looks like an applicators tail that's
that's the clothes we coming down this
levee and we saw one afar off it looked
good sighs but he popped down so try
dredging the bottom a little bit but
we'll keep moving
perfect there was a nice gainer
descended himself right there but he
slid in as soon as he saw us coming as
we have seen some big Gators but they
keep being in places we can't use the
rod and reel on so we're holding out
looking looking for a right Gator in the
right location
[Music]
yeah actually the cast is right on them
oh we got some ugly weather coming
oh there he popped up
we'll try keeping my let grass fall over
there yep perfect
here we go yep it means patience that's
a little fishing game tag that society
we're totally beat we're keeping it all
sending them back now
holy mackerel that thing just fought
like crazy that was right up there with
catching those eight-foot sturgeon man
that was fun the Magic Mike here is
going to show us how to show us how to
get some Gators all right let's go get
number two
[Music]
yep yeah that guy is a master with the
fishin rod man I've casted too ugly
stick a lot of times in my life I
thought it was pretty good I'm mediocre
that guy's good
he's popped up right there he does bomb
that right between the eyes I think
that's where you put a bang stick right
there
by the way those Gator calls knew your
sound I don't I'm no connoisseur but
that sounded legit and the alligators
are really popping up here we're seeing
them quite a few now Tommy get behind me
buddy
[Music]
got him well he is belly-up oh yeah he
looks like a twin or that other one here
perfect well guys I think the last time
I shot a rifle was shooting that
ptarmigan up in Alaska two and a half
years ago so yeah it's been a while but
apparently it's like riding a bicycle
well I think when you swim into a
gator-infested territory to retrieve a
potentially wounded Gator you get your
man card lifetime membership you don't
have to renew it annually for seven full
four well guys we've got two very nice
alligators in the tribe but we're
looking for one truly big boy this is
just an amazing hunt and these guys do
all sorts of things deers turkeys pigs
so if you guys ever want to do this
check out big old Gator hunts I'll put
links in the description to their
website and all the social media stuff
definitely if you're down here in
Florida you want to try a hunting trip
this should be high on your list what do
you think Tommy's is one of the coolest
hunting trips you've ever been on
these alligators are really skittish I'm
trying to use my lights to film but I
got to be really careful because it's
scaring them off so keeping my lights
dim down until we get him hooked to the
right a little bit holy mackerel that
was a big Gator we're on the final
stretch here
he's keeping the sharp eye out and we've
been having so much fun oh my goodness
that was another monster wasn't that
thing looks like he was gonna pull you
right off that dike hole guys I can't
believe it
we hooked into three massive Gators and
three of them broke us off as a hundred
and fifty pound test line braid there
are some big Gators and I got to tell
you it's kind of giving me an itch I
might have to come back and scratch this
is pretty awesome it is late and these
guys still got a long drive to get home
so they're gonna take the Gators back to
their place put it in the cooler and
then we're I'm going to come back in the
day time and I'm gonna film them
skinning it up and the process in it but
we're going to go through all that
alright we're back and we're gonna
process these alligators here we're
gonna skin them out also we're gonna be
doing some cooking with this alligator
meat the boys here are really excited
for Gator Nuggets and I've got Nate with
me right now
any huh now the back of the Gator all
these little scoots up here on the top
that's just like loads of bone in there
so they're basically takin everything
except for the back this will come out
one big strip and all the other skin
will come out in one piece yeah look at
that he's only got four toes on his back
legs but five on his front making these
cuts along either side of the bony
plates right down the top of the legs
there you go that's the front left leg
and of it there's only a few Nuggets
worth of meat on it the rest is as
tendons and a lot of bone I mean this is
feels pretty heavy but we're gonna see
what we can salvage off that
[Music]
there we go will you that and I body
armor
there's the scoots all right there
mr. Newport
[Music]
the best part right there get one more
then on this side then two more off the
other gave me that's the best part you
got a trim on this bad off no I'll get
you if you leave any of that on a cookie
that's gonna taste like garbage you okay
that's all gotta be clean that's that's
meat and that's bad
gotcha yeah we all soft that is
[Music]
this is what we got left over we got the
hide the back like strip of hide Jame
tail meat and some little bits that I
got off the legs back at the house and
we got a refrigerator full of alligator
meat and we are going to cook up some
alligator peanut oil so he cubed up all
the tenderloin look at that
some Everglades seasoning
check it out the Nugget all right a
little bit of pork oh yeah yeah yeah
oh look guys we do what this party needs
more no yes Lea we got two kinds of
alligator nuggets we got poncho and then
buttermilk flour nuggets I've got some
my koi dipping sauce which I'm probably
the only one who want to do that and
this awesome honey barbecue sauce
got some watermelon macaroni salad some
jambalaya with fried alligator in their
pan fried alligator fresh green beans
and warm sweet cornbread guys this is
delicious this is one of the tastiest
things you can go out and shoot if you
guys like this type of video make sure
to check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel we put out new videos every
Saturday morning we have an entire
playlist of catch and cook videos I'll
put links in the description and we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
take care have a great day if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get
issues thanks for watching